singer
songwriter do you know icon it's just
not something you ever really imagined
Gord downy along with the hip have been
providing the soundtrack to our lives
since releasing their first EP back in
1987
[Music]
14 studio albums over 8 million albums
sold 16 Juno Awards a star on Canada's
Walk of Fame yet the ban was even
awarded a Governor General's Award in
2008 when he found out what was your
reaction honor and the wildermann
diagnosed with an aggressive form of
brain cancer Gord addressed his
impending mortality and one of his final
sit-down interviews with CBC's Peter
Mansbridge I don't want to die cuz I
have my son's 10 that really scares me
yeah
you know obviously but the singer
remained optimistic giving me this long
kind of way to do some of these things
that I've always wanted to do including
going on the road with the hip for one
last series of shows
which all came to a close with an epic
final performance in their hometown of
Kingston Ontario Downey continued to
tour right up until his death with his
last solo release secret path which
includes a graphic novel an animated
film about the tragic death of a
twelve-year-old boy running away from a
residential school not only a talented
musician Gord spent many years
campaigning for several causes close to
his heart including indigenous rights
this past December Downey was honored at
the Assembly of First Nations where he
was made an Aboriginal brother he called
it quote the greatest day of his life
and in June Gord was recognized with one
of our nation's highest honors the Order
of Canada for its commitment to social
activism and raising awareness of
indigenous issues a visionary a legend a
true Canadian for Downey will sadly be
missed
[Music]
[Music]